порожні вулиці повсюди сліди від
російських обстрілів через півтора
місяця після деокупації Херсон нагадує
місто привид за даними місцевої влади до
війни в Херсоні проживали 330 тисяч
людей нині лишилося не більше п'ятої
частини 60 тисяч
щодня по обіді на міському вокзалі стає
людно звідси відправляється єдиний потяг
до Києва
до нього приєднані три евакуаційні
вагони які прямують до Хмельницького для
багатьох херсонців це порятунок від
постійних ударів російської артилерії
Велика родина іванчуків виїхала з села
токарівка на північ від Херсона як і
більшість людей в евакуаційному вагоні
вони не знають що на них чекає попереду
але впевнені що Гірше вже не буде
побачив коли
ти до останнього сиділи до останнього
вже
нельзя було залишатися не можу
Оксана з чоловіком жили в селищі
Антонівка біля славнозвісного мосту
після прильотів у сусідні двори вони
наважилися виїжджати Коли ти боїшся
находиться в будинку в себе боїшся вийти
на вулицю боїшся пройти по вулиці Це не
життя
спиш підвалі якщо вдома ти знаходишся
Так це стараюся вище щоб тебе були вони
під рукою що мало Лів друг там бігти
тікати щоб уже документи схватив і
взувся і побіг це дуже страшно конечно
у херсонця Анатолія взагалі не лишилося
вибору Його будинок зруйнований вщент
[музика]
меблі всі документи я займаюся
підводними зйомками в експедиціях з
американцями був
Підводна археологія усі роботи за 10
років обладнання водолазне
оборудование
після ночі в дорозі евакуаційний потяг
прибуває до Хмельницького
Таким чином зараз ви отримаєте допомогу
одноразову
для людей всеокупованих територій після
того як ми поїдете вже там або на місця
розселення або до своїх родичів хто куда
встаєте там на облік як внутрішньо
Північна особа за місцем проживання
Хмельниччина приймає переселенців з
Херсона з 26 листопада а від початку
війни людей з усієї України нині кажуть
в обласній адміністрації у самому
Хмельницькому місця для переселенців
закінчилися у нас повністю з березня
місяця місць вже на жаль немає в зв'язку
з тим що порядка вже 40 тисяч внутрішньо
переміщених нас проживає в місті
Хмельницькому до війни місто
Хмельницький
нараховував населення 270 тисяч
на даний час ви міста Хмельницького
Північний має
улюблених з Херсона розселяють в області
у школах і садочках які не працюють
або ВУЗ попрямує до школи у селі
Борщівка за 80 кілометрів від міста у
нас облаштовано дві душових кабіни там в
нас є дві електроплити на 8 конфорок
умови в нас нормальні як на мене
досить
комфортно теплу чисто тому просимо
підтримувати і думаємо Все буде добре
Валентина з Херсона розповідає що деякі
її знайомі виїхали з Херсона в Росію
Утім для неї було принциповим залишитися
в Україні водночас умови для
переселенців на Хмельниччині стали для
неї несподіванкою мені думали що нас ми
не думали що нас поселять у садочок чи в
гуртожиток чи може Хоч якийсь центр
знаєте щоб у сім'ї була окрема кімната
бо ми всі з дітками з мамами з бабусями
ось сім'я теж чоловік і дружина і дітки
і Кажуть що будуть селити або в садочок
усіх разом або в гуртожиток теж усіх
разом Через це засмутилися у родини
іванчуків з села токарівка поки лише
позитивні враження
подобається то що є світ
участь движения
Діти тоже кажуть бабушка значить
цивілізацію тихо ніде не стріляють наче
й Війни немає
це відремонтована сільська школа стане
для херсонців новим домом принаймні на
деякий час
то Цей заклад в якому ми перебуваємо то
ми розраховуємо на те що люди тут можуть
проживати рік 2-5 тому що заклад не
діючий звичайно якщо садочок у тій самій
радковиці Ми звичайно відновимо
навчальний процес Люди там не зможуть
проживати ми тоді будемо змушені просити
їх відшукати собі інше місце для
проживання тому що діти мусять
отримувати освіту
у колишній борщівській школі уже живуть
переселенці з Херсона серед них Віктор
кривобородько колись перший Шериф
України наглядав за порядком у селі
стара Збур'ївка на Херсонщині де вперше
в Україні запровадили таку посаду Це
село на лівому березі Дніпра воно досі
окуповане а Херсон більше не може
слугувати для Віктора і його дружини
прихистком
приход прилетіли прямо під вікно і воно
всі Осколки зібрали собі у спину
[музика]
лівий берег і ми ж додому це такий рядом
життям на Хмельниччині Віктор і Ольга
задоволені хоч і мріють повернутися
додому місцева громада раз на день
безкоштовно годує обідами благодійні
фонди передають гуманітарну допомогу
крім виплат для внутрішньо переміщених
осіб від держави безкоштовно видають
продукти харчування на місяць і одяг
водночас нову прибулі херсонці
по-різному оцінюють умови які надає
держава влаштувалися нормально прийняли
нормально
всім довольні якби
заспокоєні що не будемо очікувати де
воно прилетить чи що Не понравилось те
що кладовище поруч Ось у нас вид на
кладовища одразу якщо ви звернули увагу
Ну а так нормально Борщів нагодували
можна пару ночей спати і щось шукати
далі
у місцевій громаді розповідають що
більшість переселенців згодом шукають
окреме житло влаштовуються на роботу
вчителями лікарями на місцеві ферми і
господарства не Хмельниччині живуть уже
близько 150 тисяч вимушених переселенців
загалом по Україні лише офіційно такий
статус мають майже 5 мільйонів людей